um I was gonna say you guys you and
Alchemist put out the incredible
freestyle that went viral uh yeah
rapping over each other's beats which I
thought was genius
uh I also think we don't get enough
Alchemist rapping these days we need to
step brothers out by the way but would
you guys do a whole project like that
Rose we already got one we already got
one bro we got like all slipping in the
darkness level like joints like you know
it's gonna happen when it happened but
and it's just you guys are both rapping
yeah we stacking them up like I sent him
beats I hit send me beats and we'll just
go in send them back boom you do a verse
you do a hook like we it's just it's ill
like we're giving each other direction
just through sending joints over and
just like you know what I mean do you
guys like I wonder how that works
because like obviously you guys are both
all-time great producers is it do you
guys collaborate on the Beats together
is it like yo this is a photo of [__] I
got this a photo shoot you got let's
pick which ones we like and then or is
it like hey yeah you have a loop he's
got a loop together we honestly is so
new of a process that we we haven't even
got to cook together yet it's just been
sending [__] back and forth but we got
we got a nice slow amount of joints
already just off that so yeah I kind
kind of feel like you what you did with
that was like the what Kendrick did with
the control freak or the control record
that was my exact sentiment you know 100
just wanted to challenge the game and
have some fun and raise some questions
that's never like I never said [__]
was white no I didn't other than one
person yeah yeah you know I mean but
it's like I never said the rest of them
dudes was whack I just was like can do
do this I never seen him do this you
know what I mean I like that's that's
all it was putting in con put it in in
context in an artistic way did you and
hit make ever have a combo after your
guys's uh online back and forth nah
I just assumed it was like it was like
nice promotion for everybody right nah
that was great man for sure that was
solid I think I think you hit it on the
head because like uh who did I have oh I
had Eric Ballinger here and we were
talking about like the difference
between you guys yeah like Rick Rubin
doesn't make beats
did you like obviously I mean I feel
like I'm sure he made some of them
classes Rick Rubin says he he doesn't
know how to do anything he's there for
his taste
I don't believe that I think that's the
older Rick Rubin I know he was in there
cooking something which I don't know he
said that he he doesn't make any beats
he's there for his taste and I feel like
I mean that's like kind of the lame hit
makers and it's like you bring hit me
again because he's got an ear he's got
the Riders and then you you got it all
you could take the NPC out and you could
you know there's nothing you can't touch
you know what I'm saying we're gonna
leave it at that yeah
Jesus I just saw did in Paris just have
a new certification yeah just went
diamond yeah crazy and it's crazy
because you know that was like a few
years before the stream in there so that
was like people really buying that song
that's that's like the difference in the
game now like I just feel like
it was like a little more earned back in
the day like I just seen I spice how
long she's been out less than a year she
got a billion streets like I'm like I
spices the game is it a wild place I'll
be like I think she's out streaming like
almost everybody except like Bad Bunny
and Drake maybe that's that's incredible
you know whatever she did in her life to
get that blessing for sure but you know
just music Wise It's like wow this is
the era we in you know you gotta accept
it I guess I remember at your old house
in your studio you had like um you had
the Grammy and then you had there was
like a Michael Jordan photo or something
and then there was like um the canvas of
like when Jay and Kanye
I think they were doing it in Paris
today that was that was right there it
was a parent it was a picture in Paris
yeah
um it's crazy to think like how much
that record like kind of changes your
trajectory of like just hit boy like I
remember during that time there was like
you were you were like one of the young
producers around good music My Guy
lifted from Phoenix it did Mercy
um and I remember he was just telling me
all these stories about like being in
hotel rooms like back to back to back
with like yourself everybody everybody
what's like one of the craziest like uh
stories you could tell about like just
those days like working with gay working
with the good guys it's a lot man
definitely like that uh trip I'm sure
lifted is talking about we all went to
London one time and everybody was there
Sean pushing Two Chains you know
obviously yay just being locked in I
remember it was so crowded in the uh one
of the hotel rooms and everybody came in
because they was working on it was
either click or Mercy wanted two and
like Sean was sitting on the floor with
a mic like this like recording a hook
for one of them joints and I just I'll
never forget that Craig a was right here
change was in everybody was in there
just a room full of people and they just
was getting it done by any means like
right there